[Music]
ugly or cute that's the question
Deadpool 3 is back with a new image in
addition to Ryan Reynolds as Wade Wilson
we also get to see his new sidekick
dogpool his verdict on Instagram looks
like avocado tastes like dog
dogpool has previously made appearances
in several Deadpool comics and is a
member of the Deadpool core his
distinctive appearance is the result of
experiments with Cosmetics which
eventually mutated him and gave gave him
the power of self-healing after Deadpool
3 had a more than messy first production
phase shooting is now back in progress
we can therefore expect some New
Impressions from the film set in the
near future in addition to dogpool other
Heroes will also be featured in Deadpool
3 alongside Hugh Jackman as Wolverine
Electra played by Jennifer Garner will
also make an appearance there are also
rumors of a reunion with Ben Affleck
Daredevil Ghost Rider and Gambit fun
chaos appears to be inevitable we look
forward to the hopefully final
theatrical release of Deadpool 3 on July
26th
[Music]